c'est pas vraiment moi qui ai choisi de
thanatopracteur c'est l'histoire de ma
vie avec la mort moi j'ai perdu mon papa
dont 17 ans d'un accident de moto et je
n'ai pas pu le voir et on fait j'ai
toujours du coup été intrigué par la
mort qu'est ce qui se passait parce que
le corps était vraiment mort est ce que
la personne n'était plus là salut je
m'appelle nanou je suis thanatopracteur
depuis 15 ans alors qu'entre canato
qu'acteur fait effectuer des soins de
conservation sur les défunts mais pas
que on enlève les pacemakers ont fait
des toiles est aussi parfois ça veut
dire que les toilettes on va juste pas
injecter de formaldéhyde dans le corps
on va faire des soins de reconstruction
et parfois aussi des soins
internationale puisqu'il ya des pays qui
ont signé des conventions avec la france
pour les retours dans ces pays là il ya
obligation de soins de conservation
là je prépare mon matériel donc tout ce
qui va me servir à effectuer le soin et
si je vais préparer le liquide à base de
formaldéhyde qui va me
servir donc pour remplacer le sang
dans le défunt dans le système artériel
me permettre de pousser le sens vers la
sortie afin que je puisse le récupérer
et réduire un maximum
la décomposition du défunt en fait je
sois thanatopraxie c'est un acte invasif
donc on utilise les instruments
chirurgicaux
et c'est donc notre outil de travail
c'est le corps humain en moyenne un soin
et d'urines avait dit voilà le système
artériel et nettoyer la cavité
thoracique et aussi la cavité abdominale
m'explique quand j'ai eut découvert ce
métier à l'âge de 10 ans j'ai dit à ma
mère c'est ça que je veux faire et du
coup c'est ce que j'ai fait il ya
parfois certains de mes collègues qui
rendent pour me dire quelque chose et je
vois à sa tête que ça doit pas sentir
très bon point c'est là où je me sens le
plus en sécurité en fait
parce qu'ils peuvent pas me perdre mais
ils peuvent pas m'en faire ils peuvent
me ment dire le plus motivant dans ce
métier c'est de permettre à une famille
de se recueillir dans les meilleures
conditions possibles sans aspect visuel
chromatique sens
sans odeur sans des compositions sans
voilà donc tout ça c'est pour moi très
motivant à ce qui motive aussi c'est
quand on a une
personne très accidenté et qu'on doit
reconstruire son visage sans le
dénaturer pour que la famille puisse
revoir ça c'est quelque chose qui est
vraiment
une motivation en plus de la pression
que ça mais parce que du coup sans nom
finalement il aurait pas pu le revoir
dans cette étape il est un métier très
difficile mais c'est pas un métier
difficile
de supporter ce qu'on voit tous les
jours ce qui est parfois difficile c'est
la pression psychologique qu'on a
derrière par les pompes funèbres ou
parfois la famille où
c'est cette pression intense de réussite
après le but n'est pas de dénaturer un
être humain
ou d'en faire des poupées de cire le but
c'est justement de les laisser
avec un aspect comme la famille les
connaissait quoi là je vais parfumer la
dame je vais lui coiffer les cheveux
voilà
je vais vérifier que tout est ok alors
je vais juste repliés les affaires
qu'elle avait pour pouvoir
les rendre à la famille le travail est
terminé je vais remettre madame en cases
réfrigérées
puisque c'est ce que les pompes
finalement demandé et puis j'ai partir
sur une autre intervention